محرك بحث قوي جدا يمكنك البحث عن نصوص
وصور وكتب و مقاطع فيديو ولكننا ادركنا ان
هناك يعني تجاهلناها مهمه ل كمسلمين هي
توفير المعلومات التي يبحث عنها الشخص في
اسرع وقت في ابها حله ولكننا لم يتمكن حتى
الان من توفير كل ما يبحث عنه المستخدمه
لان بحثهم يكون اكثر من مجرد استخدام
الغاليه في بعض الاحيان لدى وزوجتي كلبه
مفعمه بالحيويه لدرجه ان لا نسمح بها ل ل
مش 5 مرات يوميا
وهي تقوم بشكل ما هو لها وهذه هي كيفيه
حصولها على معلومات حول عالمها امكانيه
توفير الروائح الافتراضيه كانت مرومه جاري
وقتا طويلا في القصص الخياليه نحن نشعر
باستشاره لاعلان خدمتنا الجديده التي تمكن
المستخدم من البحث عن الروائح برنامج
الفارس الذي طورناه يتضمن خمسه عشر مليون
من الروائح حول العالم في قاعده البيانات
يبحث عن الروائح من خلال دمج لوحات
المعرفه الحاليه لدينا
يقوم بمحاكاه الروائح مؤقته من خليني
تقاطع الخطوات مع موجات صوتيه
يعملوا على كثير من الكمبيوترات المكتبيه
والكمبيوترات اللوحيه في بعض الهواتف
الذكيه ايضا ليس لدينا الوقت الكافي دائما
للتوقف الزهور في عالم سريع الوتيره الذين
يشفيه ولكن الزهور الان على بعد كبسه زر
معكوس
اذا كنت تتسائل حول رائحه السيارات
الجديده ثم نعلم الجواب
ما هي الرائحه بداخل القرانيه
ام